[Music]
we're clearing the path so we can get
the wheelbarrow back into the woods this
trail had a bunch of windfall come down
lots of sticks and stubs and trees
we're almost done clearing except
there's a bunch of moss growing all over
the ground that we want to pick up and
save for the roof we don't really have
to save every little bit of Mars but
like this chunk definitely I take the
liberties of cutting down shrubbery when
she's not looking she doesn't want to
cut one plant you got to cut some plants
everyone likes a trim
all right now we got to decide what we
wanted here will you go over on that end
oh let's put it here and then let's go
inside
small was his smile this is smaller than
I thought it was gonna be we said small
you said small you said you wanted it
small not much no but think about it
it's enough so this is all open except
for the latter which is gonna come which
will be over here going up a little
stove a little stove couch chair table
bed well if you want to make it bigger
we can make you bigger but now's the
time to say that you want it bigger I'm
pretty sure it's big enough
I'm hoping it's big enough I don't want
to make it bigger but I'm not sure all
right let's try to make it work is it
gonna be small it's gonna be really
really small but don't we want to make
them like small not more than we need
and I thought that the floor was gonna
come up higher as the wall spread out
hexagon hexagon that looks like a portal
we've got the post smart for all six
posts and now we're sinking spade in the
soil we're gonna dig the holes for the
foundation hey this is pretty momentous
he doesn't even want to talk about it
she just wants to do it so begins
we're crushing it how are you beating me
the soil over here is way harder than
this oil right there look at this
clay dude nice when my brother gets on
the property maybe you can make some
pots with this nice gray clay because
maybe you'd like to have a pot made out
of cat and land clay look at that clay
you look like your poop on your face it
looks like runny diary on your things
well fine then I thought it would be fun
all right
those are plenty deep right there
this one is good
that looks good
now we should go wash off what time no
we can't get go we can't keep going it's
gonna get dark in less than an hour I
think we should go make a fire and dry
off you don't want to keep going
does seem that way it does seem that I'm
a harder worker and then Jacob doesn't
it you want to start hauling concrete
but as that blocks we can haul cinder
block but I don't want to put them in
the holes
all right he's ready to quit it oh hi
I'm
this world was meant to love so let's
not push and show I feel the same about
you
I'll always love you too then we can go
to the cabin land take me by my hand
and go there when we came off the cabin
land we can go to cabin land take me by
my hand go there when we can off to
cabin land
[Music]
you did
I got a rap for it - yeah - Drake cabin
land building cabin land and I got a
plan building cabins in the woods and
I'm feeling like the man cabin lamp
building cabin land with my man standing
here my girlfriend stabbed daddy and
he's giving us a hand Drake please be
sure to LIKE and subscribe this channel
so you never miss an update and please
back us on patreon so we can keep these
free videos coming yes free ain't free
we need you back us please